un an après les premières manifestations
pour la défense elle est comprise et les
trains syndicat d'enseignants du privé
ont tenu congrès très satisfaits comme
on fait du retrait diallo savary les
syndicats du très attendu maintenant les
décrets d'application des mesures
chevènement véronique bonnet à la veille
des vacances de pâques oeufs voûte volet
relate marie fénelon à paris deux mille
enfants répartis entre alité un collège
et trois écoles similaires puis l'école
molière
ici la majorité des enseignants
syndiqués leçon au snake pft ce prix ce
syndicat faire de l'ordre des
manifestations du printemps dernier
revendique aujourd'hui presque à lui
seul le retrait de la loi saba ils
totalisent 40% des suffrages aux
élections professionnelles qui comme moi
mobiliser cas l'an dernier quand on fait
les adhérents du snec tablent en
revanche assez satisfait très active et
très performante et s'il le fallait et
je crois que nous sommes très nombreux
bons couples et les nombreux mails comme
on pourrait soupçonner j'y pense souvent
quand je rencontre d'autres voitures qui
pour toujours là badge comme une sorte
de rappel en dépit c'est oublier
quelques points d'inquiétudes demeurent
sur les modalités de la décentralisation
et la nomination des nets enfin apprécié
est de rigueur
qu'en sera-t-il des budgets alloués à la
formation continue des enseignants qui
ne souhaitent pas rater le train de
l'information nous ne visons que diarra
besoins scolaires qu'il s'agit de
satisfaire si le gouvernement s'entête à
vouloir réduire les moyens de
l'enseignement privé
il est clair qu'il y aura des actions
qui sauront mesnel avec pisto qui
veulent le respect effectif de la
liberté lance elle le dit elle on le
complète et réunis à grenoble en même
temps qu'eux
duceppe chef technique est aujourd'hui
plus modéré à l'égard de jean pierre
chevènement
c'est le syndicat des autorités
diocésaines et il recouvre 27% des voix
il souhaite maintenir le dialogue il se
veut le syndicat de la troisième voie
m'intéresse encore flou dans la tente
des décrets d'application
reste enfin le troisième syndicat du
privé la fep cfdt 30% des suffrages qui
à la verse des autres continuent de
réclamer l'unification du public et du
privé pour une meilleure et la gauche et
je pense que si je suis resté dans
l'enseignement privé parce que j'ai
trouvé une manière de le travailler qui
est important pour moi est entre autres
un souci individuel des élèves
est ce que vous êtes sentis concernés
par l'accord et scanner de l'année
dernière nous parce que j'aurais
souhaité que le problème de
l'enseignement soit posé beaucoup plus
ardue la gothique et qui se
c'est tout pour moi au delà des
querelles publiques et privées kobo
nombre d'enseignants et notamment les
trois quarts qui sont syndiqués nude par
les problèmes se situent ailleurs il
n'en est pas de même pour les parents
qui se disent prêts à défier la première
occasion il est vrai que pour eux le
choix du privé et de 6 politique